and the royal family have been good to
you robert because you didn't when you
went to america
oh oh god yeah um
have i forgotten something which the
royals have done i went out with kate
middleton i forgot
um
yeah no i mean just when i
when i first came it's very easy to
convince people that you're a member of
the royal family well at least you kind
of know people the first time you go out
to where like like uh you know because i
hadn't worked for three years i was
unemployed in london and they're like
what have you been doing for the last
three years like oh i've been at radha
with uh prince william
sounds wonderful you're english i
completely believe